Allah subhanahu wa tala
tells us
in the closing verses of
he says subhanahu wa'ta'ala that which
translates to
and I have not created the gin kind and
the humankind
except so that they may worship me
so that they may worship me. Allah is
referring to himself.
You notice here that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala oftent times throughout the Quran
will refer to himself in the plural.
He will refer to himself in the plural
which is referred to in grammar in
English as the royal we.
So for instance,
[Silence]
Subhan,
that he will refer to himself as we.
And this is the royal we. The royal we
meaning it's out of exaltation. He is
exalting himself. It doesn't literally
mean
In the plural sense, it is a a type of
exaltation.
And in this verse, he did not use that.
And this is important for us to
look for when we read the Quran.
When Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala refers to
himself,
whether he refers to himself in the
singular or in the plural,
it is based on what is being
communicated in the statement.
So here Allah is speaking about
he is speaking about worship
and so he says I I have not created the
jin kind and humankind he didn't say we
why because worship is worship of Allah
alone without any partners otherwise it
is not considered worship
and so he articulates
the condition of worship worship is that
it is predicated oned.
If a person worships Allah and worships
another along with Allah in any worship
then this will invalidate their worship
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Just like
if a person makes wudoo to make salah
and then breaks his salah breaks his woo
during salah it will invalidate his
salah because there is no such thing as
salah without wudoo and there is no such
thing as worship without
and so Allah tells us here in this verse
[Silence]
He says, "I have created not the
ginankind and the humankind except so
that they may worship me."
Meaning me alone without any partners.
Here's the question that really should
come to your mind when you think about
this. When you think about this verse,
when we look at the worship of the human
being,
if you ask the average person, and we
were speaking about this two nights ago,
we were to continue this topic last
night, but we had our event, so we're
continuing it tonight.
Couple nights ago we were discussing the
issue of
what is worship?
Allah says that he has created us for
the function of worship. What is
worship?
And so if you ask this question
to the average person,
you will get not a definition of worship
but you will get examples of types of
worship. So you say for instance what is
worship? A person will say well you know
making salah giving zakah fasting
Ramadan making hajj.
Is that the epitome of worship? No.
These are types of worship. But this is
not the definition of worship.
Worship
is a general term used in the Quran to
speak about anything
that Allah loves of action or speech
of actions or speech or beliefs. All of
this is considered worship.
And worship is very broad in its
meaning. And it is possible for a person
from his moment of consciousness until
the end of his life to spend his life in
worship.
Not necessarily to spend his life making
per se or giving zak or fasting.
Rather, these are types of worship. But
if you look at the human being
and you compare the human being who was
created for worship
and then you com compare that with the
amount of worship that we do, it seems
we don't have a lot of worship to
contribute. I mean think about it. You
have what bare minimum five prayers a
day. Those five prayers could be what?
Collectively, maybe 25 minutes if we put
them all together.
Maybe 25 minutes,
maybe 20 minutes. What about fasting?
You have 12 months in a year. You have
to fast only 29 of them or 28 of them.
And there are a number of things that
could occur that will exempt you from
fasting completely. What about zak? Zak
is not obligatory upon every person.
It's only obligatory upon the wealthy.
What about Hajj? Once in your lifetime,
even if you live to be a thousand years
old, you only have to make Hajj one
time.
But we were created from war for for the
purpose of worship. Being that we were
created for worship, it seems not a
lot of worship is expected of us. That's
what it seems like. Because when you
couple that with how much of our time we
spend sleeping completely in
unconscious, how much of our time we
spend in adolescence, how much of our
time we spend in old age, how much of
our time we spend going about trying to
survive in this world,
trying to get shelter and and secure
shelter and and income and so forth
for ourselves. the amount of worship
seems very minuscule
and then when you compare that to the
angels and their worship
this is a very interesting point
because even the angels didn't all
understand
when they were told about the creation
of Adam
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said to the
angels
I am going to create the successor in
the earth. They said
they said their response, their
question,
are you going to create a creature in
the earth that is going to spread
mischief and spill blood, innocent blood
on that earth? Meanwhile, we already
exist and we sing your praises and we
glorify you and we purify ourselves for
you. Meaning that the angels are already
worshiping Allah. Listen to this
narration. The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam said
[Silence]
He said
that the heavens
are almost buckling under the weight of
the sheer amount of inhabitants. in the
heavens. He said, "There is not a place
in the heavens, the seven heavens,
not a a space of four fingers except
that it is occupied by an angel either
standing or in or in sujud to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala."
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us about
is essentially
aa a house of Allah that is above the
kaa that is on earth in the heavens for
the angels
the prophet tells us sallallahi wasallam
that it has two doors
one by which to enter and one by which
to exit and that out of worship of Allah
70,000 thousand angels each day and
night go through those doors
and they cannot hope to ever get a
second chance to do that until the day
of judgment. That's how many angels
there are.
What What does he need you and I for?
What is that for? He doesn't need the
angels,
but a creature created for worship at
face value. It seems the human
being is the lowest common denominator
in that equation
because the angels are described by
Allah and the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam to be creatures that we could
not hope to compete with in their
worship of Allah. So how can a human
being be special? How what is our
purpose? What kind of worship was Allah
speaking of when he said this?
It's not just the worship of and that
makes the human being special. The human
being has a type of worship that not
even the angels experience. Not even the
angels produce.
What kind of worship is that? A lot of
people think that the angels do not have
free will. I'm sure 90% of us here have
heard this before. That is not correct.
There's nothing in the Quran and Sunnah
that tells us that the angels are
automatons that do not have free will.
They have free will. They speak and they
choose and they have things they like
and things they don't prefer. They have
free will and they have consciousness
and they have intelligence.
But what is different between the human
being and the angel? The angel has free
will and the angel has consciousness and
the angel has freedom of choice but the
angel does not have an instinct to
disobey. That's the difference.
The human being has an internal
struggle.
A struggle that never ends.
From the moment you are born, as Shan is
there at your mother's bedside and as
soon as you come out of your mother's
womb, he is there to poke his grimy
finger into your belly. As the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam tells us
and from that moment until you take your
last gasp of breath you will fight that
fight
that's the difference between us and the
angels the angels have free will but
they have no inclination
to disobey Allah
they have no instinct no internal
they are not created from the earth
partially and from the heavens partially
they are all light. That's where they
come from. And Allah describes them.
They do not disobey Allah in the least
ever because they have no inclination
whatever to disobey Allah. Not you
and me. You and I, we have inclinations.
We know what Allah wants and then we
have what we want.
We know with our mind what is correct
and then we have these things called
feelings
that tell us the opposite that don't
follow logic.
We have as the prophet sallallah.aii
Wasallam was given the choice on the
night of Israel
brought him a bowl of milk and a bowl of
alcohol and he was allowed to choose and
he chose the milk. That's the struggle.
Those two options
they symbolize the struggle of humanity.
Do I choose what makes me feel good but
goes against what I know to be right or
wrong or do I choose what is wholesome
even if it doesn't immediately make me
feel good that's the choice that's what
makes the human being special and for
this reason Islam and we will end with
this he said
that
of the wise men of Islam who have
mentioned that the human being has the
potential to be more virtuous than
angels
and has the potential to be more lowly
than animals.
Listen to this. He says the human being
is a mixture between
impulse
and knowledge.
Impulse and decree and divine re
revelation.
The angels they have no impulse. They
have no desire to disobey Allah ever.
And so they always choose what is
correct.
The animal doesn't have a choice. The
animal doesn't have free will. They have
impulses,
nature,
instincts that the animal follows. The
human being has both. And so when the
human being chooses to obey Allah in
spite of his inclinations,
he has done something that all the
angels can't do together.
And when the human being chooses to
adhere to his impulses
in spite of divine revelation, he is
worse off than the animals because he
has now squandered that freedom of
choice, that free will and that divine
revelation. That is the worship that
Allah is speaking of here. That's what
makes us special. And so when you are
faced with a fork in the road, even if
it seems trivial, and you think to
yourself, what does Allah want from me
here, and you have the angel telling
you, come down this way, and then you
look down the other fork in the road,
and you see the devil there beckoning
you, and you obey the angel in spite of
the other path looking really nice,
then you have done something that even
angels are not capable of.
And when you choose the opposite, you
have squandered something that even the
animals cannot stoop to. A loneliness
that not even animals can stoop to. We
ask Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
that he subhanahu wa ta'ala teach us
from that which will benefit us and that
he benefit us from that which he teaches
us.
Alhamdulillah.